so we're going live in three two one
okay ladies and gentlemen good evening
and welcome to tonight's planning
committee meeting my name is councillor
richards and i will be chairing the
meeting this evening um some
housekeeping offer me to start with
first of all we
we don't think there's going to be a
fire alarm there's no plans to have one
but if one does go off if you would
please follow all of us to the car park
over the roads next to the pub we will
be able to check your names off and make
sure everyone is safely out of the
building mobile phones if you would
please turn them off or at the very
least to silent i know people need to
use them from time to time so if you
want to use them that's fine just make
sure they don't disturb the flow of the
meeting please
public it is not a public meeting so
only those people that have registered
to speak will be permitted to do so
at the appropriate time i will call you
forward to the desk in front of us there
is a hand gel and there are uh wipes as
well if you wanted to use those um
we also when you come to use the
microphone uh don't sit too close to it
because we get a bit of feedback there
is a button in the middle if you press
that button it will turn red and you
will be live please when you are
speaking please make sure that it is on
and when you finish speaking if you
could turn it off that would be
great
um some introductions
we have first of all olivia quinn our
community services representative to my
immediate right we have sue mullins our
solicitor and our planners are emily
napier and eleanor bass and we also have
sebastian onslow who is our tree
preservation officer um and richard
gardner who is to my immediate left he
is our planning manager richard i think
you've got a statement to make please
thank you mr chairman just to confirm
that my role is to provide impartial
advice and to assist members in their
decision taking thank you
thank you very much just a quick
reminder as well that we are being live
streamed and we are recording we are
being recorded for later viewing on
youtube should you so wish to watch us
back again um right let's get into the
meeting proper first of all apologies
for absence please olivia
we've got apologies from councillor
kendall and councillor rock who
counselor adam is substituting for
tonight thank you very much welcome back
counselor adam um disclosures of
interest please members i'm going to go
through a few to start with and and then
i'll call for you guys so um first of
all the first application
385 very um i have received a copy of
our war members representation tonight
uh there was possibility that she wasn't
going to be here i believe you have all
received it as well if i could have
confirmation from everyone please
that is a yes from everyone um clearly
our world member is here so we will hear
that uh that representation from her um
and
uh on the final item tpo
201131 i have been copied into
correspond correspondence between the
agent for the application and also our
planning officer um i'm not sure if
anyone else has or not but um certainly
i have um i'm here with an open mind
councilor mills i think you indicated
that you've got some
thanks mr chairman to declares of
interest on um third eye on the agenda
that's two two strokes zero one three
eight five fairy i'm the county
councillor for um
uh for upper lighthorn um but i'll come
with an open mind on that one thank you
very much and also um
on application four on the agenda two
two
oblique zero one one one seven four full
again i'm the county council for
warmington but i'll still be sitting on
and i'll be
approaching with open mind mr chairman
thank you lovely so thank you councilor
mills anyone else with any disclosures
they'd like to make
no marvelous in that case let's dive
into our first application which is
application 2201 385 very land adjacent
to the old gated road in upper lighthorn
our presenting officer is emily napier
emily over to you
thank you chair
the application relates to the variation
of condition one of reserved matters
approval 21 forward slash zero one zero
zero five forward slash rem
this was a reserved matters application
related to the green infrastructure
associated with the outline application
15 forward slash 04 200 forward slash
out to allow revision of the m40 noise
bund designed to delete the acoustic
fencing and achieve noise mitigation via
the noise band without fencing
the officer recommendation is to approve
the application for reference this is a
variation to a reserved matters
application
that was part of the outline consent so
this is not a variation to the original
outline it is a variation of the
reserved matters
in terms of the application site
the site forms part of the wider upper
light horn development which is
delivering approximately 3 000 houses
this application relates to
one of two outline applications that
were approved this is um the
commonly known as homes england part of
the site which is the northern parcel
uh marked here with the land uh
specified on the black dot
uh you can see here this is the
application site
um you have the m40 to the north and
east um with chesterton wood to the
north
um the site forms part of the upper
lighthorn new settlement this part is
owned by homes england are specified
an outline planning commission for up to
a thousand dwellings has already been uh
granted
to the northwest the m40 to the south
um is the b4 100 banbury road
the application site has a number of
public right-of-ways crossing across and
also along the old gated road it's
marked here
the northern bridge takes the old gated
road over the m40 and the southern
bridge here
takes the public right of way over the
motorway the ground levels are
significantly higher at the south
compared to the north
uh the uh the site already has the
benefit of reserve matters approval for
green infrastructure of which includes
the m40 noise fund with a two meter high
fence the current proposal as shown on
the slide is to retain the noise bund as
approved but emitting the fence and you
can just see here along this this is the
proposed noise bund that would lie
adjacent to the m40
and this would be the the future parcels
related uh to future reserve matters
applications
uh the following slides provide a brief
overview of cross-sections across the
buns
this would be uh approximately around
the northern end the cross section shows
the graded slope of the bund at the
northern end where the ground levels
drop
necessitating the highest part of the
bond construction
and you can see here the difference in
land levels approximately on the m40 and
the uh the development side so you can
see that the the bund would be
constructed um varying levels dependent
on the the land level of the m40 and the
development side so it wouldn't be one
uh steady height on either side it would
be fully um in the context of the land
levels
again you can see the changes to the
scale of the bun dependent on the
location this would be this is a
snapshot from the central area
um
and at this part the bond would be
approximately 10 meters above the m40
level with a width of around 38 meters
allowing a graded slope on both sides
for substantial part planting
again you can see this would be the
southern end
showing the change in levels dependent
on the delay the levels of a site across
the application
this uh photograph shows you um a view
towards the site taken from the listed
um
chesterton windmill you just see here at
the foot of this photograph where my
arrow is that would be
that's the application site with the m40
nestled in amongst those trees and you
can see here this is chesterton wood
this uh is of the view from the bridge
of the old gated road looking uh south
towards the application site
which is here this would be where the
bund would be located adjacent to the
m40 just showing uh those levels where
the levels are at the lowest point next
to the m40
this is taken um from the public right
of weighbridge looking northward towards
the application site here
you can just see the relationship here
with the m40
we just have an overview um of the the
parcels the wider parcel which is the
outline which is this land here
and you can see here this is where the
noise bond would run along parallel to
the m40
just to remind you the officer
recommendation is to approve thank you
chair
thank you very much indeed okay we'll
call our first speaker for the evening
who is councillor hedger from upper
lighthorn parish council
good evening and welcome
and when you've got yourself settled and
comfortable you'll have three minutes
i'll give you a 30 second warning before
your time is up and if you can stay
seated afterwards for questions that
would be great otherwise when you're
ready time's yours okay thank you very
much and um
i'm here representing upper lighthorn
parish council
and i'm particularly representing our
future parishioners who will be most
affected by this application
the application to remove the acoustic
fence is unacceptable
not only is it a dilution of the
original proposal set out in the core
strategy the supplementary planning
document and the outline planning
permission
but many of you who've been involved
with glh in the past will know how hard
local parishes work
to obtain
the best noise mitigation levels and to
ensure a high standard
it's totally unreasonable to expect
households to achieve noise mitigation
indoors through acoustic glazing and
ventilation and to not be able to use
their gardens
we're particularly concerned that this
application to removal also sets the
precedent
for the rest of the noise bund along the
new second moon
we strongly dispute the timing of this
application
and ask that the application should be
postponed until the bund has been built
and measurements can be taken
appropriately and assurance is given
that the noise level meets with that set
out by the world health organization
this development should be stratfor
district council's flagship
and as such stratfor district council
should be seeking to meet all options to
provide a desirable high quality town in
which to live
not somewhere where it isn't possible to
open windows and doors for ventilation
or enjoy being out in a garden
upper light on request that the
committee consider rejecting this
application
however should it go forward we would
like to request that it is mandatory
that the noise measurements are taken
again and if they fall short of world
health organization standards then the
acoustic fence should be put in place
thank you
councillor thank you very much well
within your time uh members do have any
questions for our counselor
counselor curtis
thank you very
much you
mentioned
that the parish council is part of the
question of time
um
would you be able to say that if the um
builds
or after
measurements
satisfy the who
requirements
is it the position that the parish
council would then be happy for the
defense
sorry you're free to answer that
question counselor curtis you you may or
may not have forgotten to turn your
microphone on
thank you
um sorry shall i start again yeah um
where was it yes so uh you thank you
very much you mentioned this question of
timing would the position of the parish
council be that
were the bond built and the noise levels
were then found to be within world
health organization limits the parish
council would be happy for the fence
then not to be built because it wouldn't
appear to be necessary
i think there's two things there yes it
wouldn't appear to be necessary however
i think i'll just go back to my point
that this is a development alongside a
motorway and it's homes that you know
i think
if it were me i would want the option of
being able to open my windows i would
want the option of being able to enjoy
my garden so i think and i think i speak
for all of my uh parish councillors that
we should be looking to
include as much as we can to enhance
that area
thank you very much any other questions
members
no in that case countries thank you very
much for your time contribution
okay we'll call our next speaker on this
item who is councillor smith chairman of
lighthorn parish council
good evening councillor smith
uh in the same way you'll have three
minutes i'll give you 30 second warning
uh as soon as you're ready to start you
press the button in the middle otherwise
the floor is yours okay
lightweight parish council are here
today to support apolitol
in representing some seven thousand or
so residents yet to occupy the new
development of three thousand houses
we are seeking to ensure that these
residents will not have to enjoy
noise levels that exceed world health
organization accepted levels
it's easy to get lost in the catalogue
of planning conditions requiring
noise mitigations and the technical
reports
seeking to justify weakening those
mitigations however the context of our
objection is a situation where in order
to meet world health organization levels
it appears to be accepted that for some
properties special window glazing will
be required and that windows be kept
closed
this is not a context where further
reduction in noise mitigation is
appropriate
we can test
that seeking permission now to remove
the obligation to erect a noise barrier
on top of the bund is premature we
suggest that instead
new comprehensive noise measurements
should be taken once the bundle is
constructed
and that application to dispense with
the noise barrier should only be
submitted if those measurements show
that noise levels for all properties
will be below world health organization
recommended levels
if you decide to allow this variation
then we request that a new condition be
placed on the approval
requiring that new comprehensive
measurements are taken once the bund
construction is complete and then if
these show noise levels in excess of who
recommended levels then further
mandatory mitigations must be applied
which could include but not be
restricted to the erection of the noise
barrier as required by the original
planning consent
castle smith thank you very much again
well within your time members do we have
any questions for our counselor please
no
in that case cancer smith thank you very
much for your time and contribution this
evening
okay our next and final speaker on this
item is councillor jackie harris
councillor harris you'd like me your way
forward
quick comment
um i'm i i'm afraid i do have to start
the time you do have five minutes i'll
give you thirteen more times
okay thank you
good evening everyone as you can see i'm
here supporting all my residents
and all the local polish councils
[Music]
i agree with everything that they said
this evening in my view is that the
application to remove the acoustic
expenses the dilution of the original
proposed settings supplementary planning
document and outline planning commission
to glh
it is unreasonable to expect households
to achieve noise mitigation indoors
through acoustic glazing and ventilation
i am concerned granted it will set a
precedent for the town along the rest of
the bond i also would like to draw your
attention i also live near the m14 orbit
albeit miles away councillor harris i'm
i'm very sorry to stop your flow
um i'm being told that we you can't be
heard on our recording can you just
check your microphone is on please hello
is it on
and your lights yeah on you might need
to bring it a little bit closer to you
if that's all right talk a bit louder if
you would sorry i'm quite softly spoken
sorry you know i'm gonna i'm gonna stop
your time restart it if you want to
start from the beginning again just so
we can pick it up for the recording that
would be great okay well i'd like to
commend tony horton for his
professionalism as an officer and i
think he's a credit to this council but
i'm here this evening to support my
residents future residents and local
parish councils who live in around the
small town called a polite home
my view is that the application to
remove the acoustic fence is the
dilution of the original proposal set
out in supplementary planning document
and outline planning permission for
jeerheurge excuse me it is unreasonable
to expect households to achieve noise
mitigation indoors through acoustic
glazing and ventilation i'm concerned
granted it will set a precedent for the
town the rest of the bund
i have to draw attention i also live
near the m40 and all be extremely far
away it is very noisy and it's height
it's
peak times
it's uh quite loud i believe the plea
from myself and particularly the parish
council should be listened to and the
committee questioning the time of the
application and postponing the
application for further work to be
undertaken
i request that this is a major
development the biggest outside of
stratford that the committee carries out
a site visit and discuss the concerns
raised
i agree with the parishes on their
request that the planning committee
reject the application
if it is to progress then i would
request that conditions are placed on
any grant
or permissions that will be mandatory
that noise measurements are taken that a
comparison is made against the world
health organization guidelines and
standards
and if the measurements fall short
further mitigation be put in place
committee please take note of the points
made in relation to the following
pointed out by tony horton the
environmental statement including the
outline planning application
1504.22 it's four to zero zero out
concluded that the noise screening from
the m40 could take the form of a seven
meter high solid earth bund or a
combination of a bun together with
acoustic barrier i.e events
outline planning was granted on this
basis subject to detail technical design
of the noise burned
that tony horton reported on the
application 21
01005 rem set up that height of the bun
should vary between 12 meters high on
the western end of the site and six
meters at the eastern the bund approved
at this stage was in places considerably
higher than previously expected
the current application uses a seven
meter high bund and seeks to remove the
fence the initial computer models
concerned a seven meter high bun with no
fence and the conclusions were that the
world health organization guidelines
could not be achieved over the site and
stated that enhanced mitigation measures
were needed windows closed enhanced
glazing etcetera these measures form
part of the basis of the objection by a
lighthorn parish council and others
it is agreed by all of us that the
applicant has failed to show that a
seven meter high bund is adequate there
are still areas where windows closed and
enhanced glazing are necessary and noise
levels in gardens will exceed who
guidelines
before a decision is made could the
committee please consider requesting
further modelling be carried out that
the developer be required to submit
further modelling results to find out
whether increasing height of the bundle
of the critical length would result in
noise levels acceptable to the who
guidelines
this is a flagship project for all of us
and we want to get it right and make
this a great place to live
for the sake of a little more time and
work we can reassure all ourselves with
the further evidence and ensure we have
a new build stroke town
to be proud of and not dogged with
issues for the sake of getting it right
first time now
thank you chair
councillor harris thank you very much
indeed members do we have any questions
for our ward member please
no
in that case council harris thank you
very much for your time contribution
okay let's move to
points of clarification to our officers
councillor jennings first please
do we have any options in the form of
conditions
um if the bond doesn't work and the
noise level exceeds the who levels
yes as mentioned this is a variation to
a reserve matter so it's not seeking to
change the outline if you hold on two
seconds i can actually just take you to
a
snapshot of a condition
this is condition 30 which is attached
to the outline this is not being changed
as part of this application this is not
related to it so
as part of any future reserve matters
submission that contains housing they
will still have to demonstrate a noise
reduction scheme
for that phase
um as part of the reserve matters and as
part of that you can see um within the
condition there's four
specific items that they will have to
demonstrate and that ensures that the um
specifically really the internal
arrangement of those properties um is is
satisfactory um and accords with with
that condition so in
removing um the fence we are not
removing any future um assessment and
ability to ensure that the internal uh
living environment for occupiers um
is is acceptable thank you chad
um i'm just going to have a follow-up on
that first of all we can see some
decibel levels on there a b c and d
those presumably murray up with the who
requirements
um and they're setting stone now on that
reserve matters and outline
okay thank you um
i did have another question but i forgot
what it was so i might come back to that
uh counselor adam next please
thanks might be one for solicitor just
in regards to um
the the parish councils asked that this
might be deferred i just want to explore
whether that was an option that we could
explore or whether that would push it
into non-determination something like
that
did we honor the decision makers tonight
if you want to defer you can defer but
you need to come up with a very good
planning reason to do so but essentially
what's the scope of a deferral can we
say it can be deferred until that point
until what point and that we that it's
built and we can and they can take noise
levels
thank you chair obviously if you did
choose to um to defer to some future
date then um the applicant would be
perfectly within their rights to appeal
against non-determination and and the
decision would be taken out of the
council's hands
thank you
i think i've remembered what our
question was uh so your response to
cancer jennings was that there are other
options to make sure that these noise
levels are maintained which ultimately
means that at a future date it may well
be that either the fence or some other
form of mitigation could be put in place
to make sure that the decibel levels
contained within
uh this this picture are met
uh yes i think it's it's perhaps
pertinent to point out that there
whilst this there is a slight
change in parts um between the
bond with the fence and the bond without
offence
um
the the level of mitigation that would
be required for future occupiers would
be the same so defense would not be
achieving
um a level of of noise mitigation that
would would
would mean that they don't need to have
additional mitigation so ventilation um
additional sort of glazing measures um
and so
as i say the the emission of the fence
doesn't change that position so it would
still be required if the fence was there
counselor curtis you had a question i
think
i suppose he's trying to pick up and
understand
that these internal measurements because
what
correct me if i'm wrong i may have
misunderstood this but seem to be saying
that
um other mitigation could be carried out
but that would be that would be things
like
additional glazing keeping windows
closed and so on and so forth
but that doesn't actually address the
noise levels
from the motorway itself
i mean it does it internally but
externally those noise levels are still
there and
it i'm
not too
easy
uh with having to sort of keep all your
windows shut and have quadruple glazing
to
reduce the noise level to an acceptable
level
in a nutshell
thank you chad um
we're getting into something very
technical here so i will i'll give you
my um my professional view on it but
obviously i'm not an environmental
health officer
the
the position is is that um
the
the bond
will provide a level of mitigation but
in order to get the internal
arrangements um
to meet the
the necessary um sound levels
the
additional mitigation will be required
it is often a case when you are you are
building next to um
areas with high traffic volumes it's
it's it is something that's
i've seen before in in you know in my my
history
what's perhaps
worth setting out is that when the
outline
was um assessed and went through
a decision
uh the environmental statement that was
submitted with it acknowledged that and
and i know the councillors um have
referred to this
um that it was either a seven meter high
solid earth bund or a combination of a
band or fence but at the same time it
did accept
that
additional mitigation to achieve the
internal noise arrangements would still
be required so even at the outline
you would still need that additional
mitigation on top of that does that
sorry thank you
um so
can we actually
can you say
uh and forgive me if you if you can't
understand it because there's so much
technical information in here
what the
anticipated reduction in noise level
of the fence would actually be because i
think that's fairly important for us to
understand thank you
i can't give you a specific number and
the reason for that is that um the the
noise survey that was submitted provides
a lot of data
there is a large number of receptors
they will make their assessment um and
and their modeling based on the the
noise at those receptors
each receptor they have um done a
comparison
um
and in i think the the majority if not
all of those circumstances from from
what i've seen um it's seen as
negligible which means that the
the change in levels is of a level that
would not be um
noticeable to to to the human ear in
effect that it wouldn't change um the
level of amenity that would have been
afforded
with a fence so it's it's whilst there
is a change in parts and it's not all
receptors where
that change um
is
is is measured um
but from what i've seen it was it varied
from 0.4 in some locations to to 2 in
others
and i think the baseline and as i say
i'm not an environmental health officer
so this is just my understanding of it i
think they say that it's between naught
to
um db is is not seen as a significant uh
change
council cramp next please
i'll give us a chance i've got three
three small questions um first the an
acoustically mechanically
ventilated
unit or whatever
off there
for a bedroom that
can't have the windows open
so one obviously we've had some rather
hot weather recently
so be interesting to not have the
bedroom window open but two if that's
the case we're having to have these
mechanical ventilators
we're trying to have properties
that are have green credentials
and therefore there's going to be some
energy potential energy usage
of these ventilators you might be using
solar panels to ventilate it but
this we are there is some
some potential energy use there so
obviously when we're trying to encourage
our properties to be as green as
possible so
that doesn't sit very well with me but i
can understand the need for it because
it's the case of sweltering cancer
cramps are i'm going to push you for a
question please
okay how does the mechanically
ventilated power
units with the windows close fit in with
our green issues when we're trying to
make our
our properties as green as possible
and it's secondly
i've got a point about
the bond
um and the environmental health
statement it says it's still not clear
whether a true 7 meter high bond has
been modeled
well if we haven't got that clarity
around that bond
why would why didn't we go back and find
out whether it was
a true 7 meter high bond
and thirdly
it says it doesn't accept a significant
increase is is
likely so
what evidence has the person got to
accept that
what is significant a significant
increase
and
how much is the increase likely to be if
we didn't have it so
thank you chat and i think it's it's
worth
pointing out that
the the condition that you i think
you're probably referring to in terms of
the attenuated mechanical ventilators is
a scenario that we are
accommodating that may crop up there's
no guarantee that it would be needed
obviously we can't um
get too embroiled in in
how
the ventilation would come forward
because as i say it's going to be
required regardless of whether there is
a fence or not um we
thank you
um
yeah so
it's i can't answer that question
truthfully but it may well be because
mechanical ventilation isn't going to be
needed we would have to assess that at
the point that that reserve matters is
submitted and they would have to provide
um the noise
scheme for that's that part of the site
obviously
attenuation um and mitigation is one
part of that but the mitigation isn't
just the the glazing and the ventilation
that's required we would also be looking
at the layout is the layout appropriate
have they looked um to try and ensure
that there's minimal um
bedrooms living rooms that are fronting
onto the road but also we would be
looking at garden areas you know do they
have access to to to what i would regard
as respite so yes they might not
necessarily be able to open windows on
the front elevation but they may be able
to open them for that ventilation on the
rear they may have access to gardens
that don't have the same
noise exposure so there's a lot of
things that we would be having to
consider at the reserve matter stage
that i don't i can't get into at this
point because that's not what we are
in effect considering in terms of the
other questions that you asked
um
the the modeling and the
the um the methodology is not something
that i can advise on at all i'm afraid
because
what what we do is we will rely on our
the professional expertise of our
colleagues in environmental health who
will review that um and what we have to
take from it is that
they consider
that
you know they can support the
application that they don't consider
that they could support a refusal based
on the information that has been
provided so that's really the baseline
for us thank you chad
yep
i think it's it's i think it's a
reasonable quest that for if we're
having such complicated
items
such as this
um two small paragraphs in a report
it would be better if we had some
reassurance
of the you know the methodology
obviously you know i'm a
finance geek so but
if there's more information available
for us to make meaningful decisions are
you are you asking a question or you're
making a statement well i'm asking the
question for it to be
for future reference if it could be a
future reference that is noted and we
will have a look at into doing that for
you and it was just like i think i i
will i will slightly rephrase what you
were trying to say there is
um the acoustic report that's been
provided to us and on which a decision
has been made
and is being made um
has been reviewed by our environmental
health officer who
does have the expertise to understand it
presumably he would not have said i'm
happy with this
if that either hadn't been conducted in
the appropriate way and the num the
decibel levels were not suitable in
accordance with um condition 30 of the
reserve matters
i would like to think that they would
not be
giving their support for an application
if they felt that the the information
wasn't available for them to make that
recommendation
thank you
council fleming
part of my question's already been asked
by
by andy um the thing is the
justification for taking this fence aid
appears to me that would they've
obviously costed this in in their
original costings and it's a cost saving
exercise to take it out and we keep
hearing the word significant or
insignificant but what we know is and
this is where the question is
the uh the decibel level is a
logarithmic scale so if it's 10 decibels
is one 12 decibels there's nearly four
times the amount of noise so
what's the difference between with the
bund without the sorry with the bun and
with the bun with the fence is is there
a is there a numerical number you can
put on that i i think that question was
asked earlier by councillor curtis and
has been responded to and i'll just
remind you of that
um uh did tell us you couldn't put a
specific number on it but it was about
um the significance uh or otherwise and
that would seem to be between not point
uh naught to three decibels
of
basically not significant and that's the
this that's the what has been
provided to us by the eho so naught to
three which is not
audible to us essentially
i think i had another question from
cancer jennings
i'm just amazed at your eyesight because
you managed to read my notes and ask
exactly the question i was going to ask
so it's been done great minds great
minds
anyone else with any other questions
before we move to the debate
no in that case let's get into the
debate who would like to kick us off
council jennings top man
again
so we're not technical experts here we
have to rely on the technical expertise
and information which we're given
condition 30 seems to
give us options in the future um
and we of course as the planning
application goes through we will have
options
at that stage as well
um
at the moment i i can't offer a material
planning reason to go against the
officer's recommendation
um that's where i stand at the moment i
won't make a proposal yet but i'll
i'll let everyone else join in
casa mills please
yes thanks mr chairman um
as we all know this is a very large
settlement it's the largest one outside
stratford
um
my feeling is that uh
that nobody should be able to live next
to a motorway in that full stop
and because as um
council hedges said this is this is a
flagship
uh development for sdc
and we have to make it as comfortable as
possible for anybody that lives next to
that motorway whether it's one decibel
two decibels
we've got to make it as comfortable as
possible
we've got to retain this fence
for the sake of that people live in
exo's motorway so
my proposal is um chairman to retain the
fence and go against the office
recommendation thank you mr chairman
thank you council mills i'm going to ask
you to think about um clear planning
reasons for that um
i think you've probably got them cancer
adam please
thanks um i'm much in agreement with the
councilor mills i think it's uh there's
to my mind a degree of ambiguity in the
response we've had from our
environmental health
based on the two paragraphs within this
report at least
it might be more detail elsewhere um and
i think actually it's the idea that we
should be going above and beyond and
i've got a big thing about lots of
different planning applications where
incremental changes might all seem
insignificant but actually they do have
a cumulative
impact and that's saying it's you know
negligible or small doesn't mean it
you know actually the react the reality
of that is not
is not insignificant and i think that
that is material to
to set um to an extent um
i'm very happy to second council of
mills and i'm happy to kind of explore
um
the hard and fast planning reasons i
think there might be something under cs
9 which will kind of assist us with that
so that's the direction i'm going in but
uh that's my thoughts for now thank you
very much council curtis thanks please
thank you um
were we to i mean i i'm actually
much in agreement with
councillor adam and mills and
um picking up the the parish council of
the objections it it does seem to be
premature i'd much rather we had the bun
built additional measurements taken
and and then and then decide on what
should happen i just know looking at
page 10 of the report though um noted
removal of the fence open up some parts
um and
allowed planting on the development
were we minded to go with the office the
recommendation will we be able to
condition
planting on top of the bun there's some
mitigation
there's already planting
there is already planting proposed um
this is a tricky one and i'm i will need
your support on this my understanding
this is a very of an already approved um
scheme
adding conditions
to an already approved scheme when we're
varying becomes very difficult because
we don't have all of the information
about what has already been included in
that scheme so i would be wary of it
we it is in with our it is within our
gift of decision makers to do that but
we need to have very strong reasons to
do it otherwise we could end up finding
ourselves at an appeal and then the
conditions we put in would be or could
be removed um is that a fair assessment
or would you like to anything add
anything
there is planting already okay thank you
have you finished with your speak anyone
else want to speak before i chuck my two
pennies worth in cancer crumb
yeah i would say i'm in agreement with
cancer adam i don't think variations um
changed by stealth
is the terminology of you i've heard in
the past um
obviously when the application went in
the defense was deemed necessary
um
whether we've got enough planning
reasons to go against
officers recommendation i nearly said i
was gonna sit on the fence on this one
but i won't
um
sorry for cancellation
but this one yeah i'm not happy about it
and if it was approved
i think we've got a duty as part of a
reserve matters to hold them to account
and make sure whatever conditions
are
as strong as possible and we've got all
the information i've got no reason to go
against the
environmental health officers
information based on the assurances from
the officers know
but
i do not like this at all but i'm
struggling to find real strong funding
reasons to go against officers
recommendations
thank you council crm council dixon
the report makes uh some sort of
comments towards the end i think
regarding the landscaping
and the fact that removal of the fence
might actually have an improvement on
the the views etc of the
site
and
help with vegetation etc in due course
as somebody who uh
bought my first property
when the king's cross main line between
king's cross and edinburgh
was at the bottom of the garden
i am aware of noise issues etc but at
the same time i'm also aware that we've
got
our
technical experienced environmental
health officers
advising that this is
an acceptable scheme an acceptable
within the limits and
in the event that world health
figures are not achieved as it were by
the bond and that there are properties
which will require that additional
ventilation under condition 30
i'm going to be supporting the officer's
recommendation on this one and i think
it is
a situation whereby if we go against it
we could be having that appeal
because essentially um
we are being given the all the technical
advice and we want to try and to re and
go against it i think that's difficult
thank you cancer texans our proposal
yes german thank you
anyone else want to speak for us through
my oren
no okay um i'm going to agree with
councillor dixon and second his proposal
to grant in line with the office of
recommendation let me explain why um
we've heard from councilman mills who
has said that we need to make it as
comfortable as possible for residents
within this um what within our entire
district but particularly within this
development i agree wholeheartedly we do
that's why we have condition 30 in the
reserve matters which clearly sets out
rules and decibel levels for the
occupiers of those homes both in terms
of their residential amenities to the
outside their garden areas but also
within their homes both at in daytime
and nighttime
this doesn't change that whether we
include defendants or not it does not
change those rules mitigation must be in
place to ensure that those decibel
levels are maintained
cancer adam talks about the cumulative
impact of variations again i agree
cumulative cumulative impacts of these
variations do have an impact on a
development
but this particularly hinges on the uh
sound levels that are
essentially mitigated by this this fence
this two meter high fence
again we have hard and fast rules within
condition 30 of our reserve matters that
clearly states the level of decibel
of noise within people's residential
immunity and within their homes at
certain hours um
i think a couple of other people spoke
about similar sorts of things as
well
i think so i think counts uh i think
council chrome talks about um duty as a
whole to account
my answer is the same we have that role
in condition 30. um
yes
the removal of the fences as council
dixon talked about it's on page nine and
ten of your reports within uh landscape
um section
it does say that there is improv there
could be an improvement or would be an
improvement by in terms of the openness
i agree with that um entirely so there's
another benefit to it but i do think
this hinges on the on the sound levels
our environmental health officer would
not have said he cannot maintain his
objection
if that report
showed that those levels could not be
achieved we've heard that
the the difference between having the
fence and not is not significant
and that
level of decibel noise is between zero
and three decibels
there is the opportunity at a later date
to include further mitigation and that
could include a two meter high fence in
this area um
if
the
condition 30 and the desperate levels
were on condition 30 of the reserve
matters is not met
i cannot find
a clear cogent and reliable planning
reason to go against the officer's
recommendation that would hold up about
an appeal should it get that far so i
cannot
support a refusal of this application
now unless anyone else wants to speak we
do have uh two proposals on the table we
must take the first one first which is a
proposal to refuse
i do need to explore your reasons your
planning reasons why where you would
like to refuse that now counselor adam i
just saw you stick your hand up do you
want to continue in the debate or you
are you wanting to come back on the
reasons if it's the reasons i want to
come to council mills first as the
proposal
okay councilman mills could i have your
planning reasons for the refusal please
yeah plenty of reasons um
i don't know if we can put health and
well-being as a planning reason probably
not mr chairman
but we we are looking at health and
well-being of our residents and to me
that is paramount
and uh we should seek to um
to enhance that mr chairman that's
probably not a good planning reason but
that's my feeling thank you
cancer adam we are going to need
something stronger than that if you can
please
um
looking at cs9 c which is design
innovation
i would potentially argue that
inclusion of the fence
is a
innovative approach to
addressing the noise levels externally
to improve the quality of life and
healthiness as per cs
be
eight
and they supplement each other and so
specifically including it would be an
innovative approach to a large
development outside of stratford town
itself and that that's more
strong in terms of material
matters
if i could have a response from this
responder my personal review is and if
it offense is an innovative approach
i'll pass you some straws to clutch out
but
yeah i i think you've hit the nail on
the head chairman um
a fence can be seen up and down the
country on motorways it's it's a
commonplace uh method of dealing with
the noise from from busy roads so um no
i i would have to disagree that it's the
innovative point wouldn't be met under
cs9
council curtis well just
um just something that
we just heard from plenty of the
fences yes
fences are
commonplace
in noise mitigations
noise mitigation on motorways
up and down the country
so presumably they must have some
significant effect
we are looking at this site in
particular
and we need to consider the effect and
the evidence of this site we have a
sound report that shows that the
inclusion of that fence would have
an
a non-significant impact on the sound
levels within the residential immunity
and with the homes and we still as i've
said and i'll reiterate it again we
still have condition 30 of the reserve
matters that clearly sets out the
decibel levels that must be met those
are the who levels they must be met and
we are not changing that
i'm going to look to everyone else can
anyone else that may be considering
going against the officer's
recommendation like to put forward clear
planning reasons that
we can
use in in a potential refusal
cancer crime can i
um simply put the conditions back up
about the decibel noise levels please
there's just
one point i might wish to rise depending
on the figures that are available there
i can tell you what the figures are if
you like i've got them written down yeah
gone
for the bedroom within within the
residential amenity area 55 decibels
within the living spaces and bedrooms
between the hours of 7am and 11 p.m 35
decibels and then uh in the evening so
11 p.m to 7 a.m 30 decibels with the
windows closed
yeah so can i just
explore a
point i know richard i think said that
without this fence
it's potentially between one and three
decibels
is that right
bear with me
not to three is what i said not to three
so potentially at the highest level it's
three decibels which is ten percent
of the eleven o'clock at night till
seven a.m
figure of 30.
so
whilst we've said it's not a significant
increase it could potentially be
a significant 110 percent so let's just
i'm just raising that point
if anybody wanted to make use of it
what can i just come back
just to pick up on the point of the
figure three decibels was mentioned
there that the figures that we we've
quoted are much closer to between around
one
the the figure of three was quoted
because that's the threshold where it
stops being negligible these are well
below that even in this case
absolutely the decibel level in here was
not high enough because i didn't know
that properly
i can increase my decibels if it would
hurt i think councillor crump might be
facetious um
so uh just to come back on that
regardless of whether that offense is
there regardless whether it's 10 or not
um those rules still have to be applied
and mitigation other forms of mitigation
or
introduction reintroduction of this
fence line could come back at a later
date to make sure that they are met
what we're here tonight to decide is
whether or not we can vary the uh um the
plan
uh the reserve matters sorry to remove
the fence at this stage it may well be
that it's reintroduced when
further work is done
now i'm still not hearing any clear
strong planning reasons to go to refuse
so unless i get one of those i am going
to look to our proposal and second to
see if they still want to maintain their
proposal
just just as a real trains chairman the
even the developers have got a duty of
care to their residence as we have mr
chairman
um
i'll be very disappointed this um
if this wasn't retained um i'm
struggling for planning reasons and
hopefully someone's clearer than me can
come up with thing thank you
counselor adam
i'll maintain seconding the application
the proposal though i'd like to vote
i think the only thing i can think of to
try and tie this into innovation
is the idea that the whole site is an
innovative development within the
district and that was kind of plain from
the outline and the reserve matters that
we're looking at
and so this application
is part of that
development on the whole and so
the
potential negative impacts of this no
matter how marginal
do stand to negatively impact the
innovative
effect that this site
is
having on our district
so i still go with cs 9c
if we're going to vote on it
thank you just give me a second please
so just to advise on the point
if i've understood you
correctly
um the innovation lies in the fact that
we're building a new town where
previously we haven't built one so
that's innovative
i would say that that would still stand
whether the fence is there or not the
fence isn't key to making the
development innovative it would still be
innovative it's in the context of the
whole development it's a very small part
save the money i know there's not plenty
of reason but they're just out to save
money mr hammer thank you developer that
is
i am it's irrelevant
i absolutely disagree with this
uh direction and i will not be voting to
support your proposal
but to help you
um
commit
committee have
in considering all the evidence that's
placed in front of it do not consider
that uh the removal of friends
sorry do not consider that the
sound mitigation of the fence is
insignificant or you consider it to be
significant
and will refer to the
10
of the night time
and that is why we consider it not to be
insignificant
and therefore you determine that it
should be included in order to
provide appropriate sound mitigation for
the future occupiers of these residences
there's a real mouthful and i'm sorry
but that's the best i can do yeah i i
would
accept that i think that would be cs 9
um we'll let the officers work out which
cs it is yeah um councillor curtis yeah
sorry just be
that's most helpful of you jerry i think
um
so
i understand essentially i think
you're saying that this committee
can decide we have the power to decide
what is significant or not
and we could
conclude that what could be up to three
percent in our view
is significant
sort of
kind of yes and it's not three percent
is through decibels which would be ten
percent of the nighttime 30 decibel
limit um
yes we as a committee as decision makers
on this application can disagree with
our environmental health officers report
he's the ex he or she is the expert in
this but we don't have to necessarily
agree
um and the reasoning for that is is that
percentage that and the decibel and the
significance etc etc
that is the best i can come up with and
i'm not sure it's going to be held up at
appeal should this go to appeal we need
to be mindful of that but if that's your
direction that's what you want to do
that's fine um
richard could you give us your view on
that as a reason for refuse a reason to
go against offers recommendation and
refuse please
um
yeah it seems to be uh
founded on an understanding of
percentages around decibels
um i'm not in a position to advise you
on that because i'm not an environmental
health officer if that would be the what
the committee refused it on
um it may be safer to defer it to take
advice from an environmental health
officer
i i'd be misleading committee if i
suggested
that that was an appropriate way forward
thank you just let me get some legal
advice
okay just so we're clear i'm just
getting some clarification on the order
in which we have to take our proposals
they have they do have to be taken in
order
we've had a proposal to refuse we're
struggling to get the reasoning for
we've had a proposal to grant
if a proposal to defer were to come it
would come after we've had a vote on the
grant
so we may well fight and i i'm judging
from the reaction of our councillors it
may well be that that fails but
we um that would be the order in which
it's taken so just be mindful of that
when we're going through this now
so can you can you just clarify please
what
the motion to defer
would be
um the motion
so what we've just heard from uh our
planning manager is that if we are
because we're we're not experts and our
planner manager is an expert in um
acoustics and sound we would want to
defer
the planning application to get further
information in terms of the desperate
levels etc etc etc
we're in a position where
we have a proposal to refuse
but we do not have a solid planning
reason for it
we can that the reason that
has been provided
could be used and we could take a vote
on that or if your money to defer so we
can get that um
that clarity
we would have to have the proposer or
the second
remove their proposal or seconding we
would then have to go to our second
proposal which is the grant
then we would have to go to the deferral
so i just want you to be clear on that
we are struggling with the reason and
our planning manager said he cannot
advise you on it so you need to be
mindful of that if that were to go to
appeal my personal view is extraordinary
weak and we have evidence but that's my
personal view you are entitled to make
your own decisions then take your own
view on that
so we can either do that take that vote
based on that and and potentially refuse
on an extraordinary weak ground with no
supporting evidence from our
environmental health officer
we then or we go to our second proposal
which is the grant and see where we go
with that and if that fails we then go
to the referral
can i seek uh from either our proposal
or our second whether they want to main
they both want to maintain and go ahead
with the vote based on the um
the reason for refusal uh even though we
haven't got any ho to give us their
guidance
predicament here mr chairman um
i think i still like to go ahead i'm i'm
i just don't like this um it's it's
awful thank you don't like it and uh
we've been down this route before but um
i still maintain this duty of of care
for our residents which gym so i
maintain you're maintaining your
proposal counselor adam
could i withdraw my seconding of that
proposal but propose that we defer
you can indeed and i'm i'm assuming your
proposal was deferred to get more
clarity around the decibel levels as you
can as you know yes yes thank you
okay yes you can i would need to seek a
seconder for that i i see councillor
crump his hands gone up all over the
place so we'll record council trump as
the seconder for that
council dixon you and i you have
proposed to granting line with the
officer's recommendation are you willing
to maintain that or would you like to
withdraw it so that the um we can defer
and get more information
i'm happy to continue with my proposal
chairman
and as am i as the seconder so we will
now take a vote on
our committee services representatives
have given me a very valid point that i
forgot and overlooked and i apologize to
you all council mills has maintained his
proposal so i must seek a second for
that
none okay
we have to we have to do that make sure
we're right so thank you very much
olivia for making sure we did that so we
have a proposal on the table now that is
to grant in line with the office
recommendation could i please have a
show of hands for those in favor of
granting
four those against
one two three four five six
six so that failed so therefore we have
a proposal to defer so we can seek
further clarity from our eho uh that has
been proposed by cancer adam seconded by
councillor crump could i please have a
show of hands if those in favor of
deferral
six
those against
four
so we've committed therefore
resolves is the word i was looking for
forgive me this is it's been quite
difficult committee therefore resolves
to defer application 2201 385 vary for
the reasons that we have given
right thank you very much
let's move on to our next item
so our next application is application
2201174 ful and also 2201175
lbc this is the cottage on the green in
warmington our presenting officer is
once again emily napier emily whenever
you're ready it's over to you
thank you chair um the application
proposes the erection of a two-story
rear extension to the existing dwelling
a listed building situated in warmington
the officer recommendation is to refuse
the application
the existing building is a grade two
listed dwelling and forms part of a pair
of iron stone cottages
it is situated on the green in
warmington the dwelling is also located
within the cotswolds area of outstanding
natural beauty and the wilmington
conservation area the adjoining cottage
is known as pond cottage and is also
listed
at the rear the property appears
relatively unaltered whilst the existing
conservatory due to its design affords
the property and ensures that the views
towards the rear of the dwelling ensure
that it continues to be red as a whole
you can see here this is the existing
floor plan with the rear single storey
conservatory
and this is the adjoining dwelling to
the north which isn't listed and that's
their uh garage that butts the boundary
this is the proposed two-story rear
extension block plan
and you can see here this is the
proposed elevations
with the two story rear extension being
attached with a glazed infill extension
you can see here the
the height of the extension would
be greater than the eaves of the
existing cottage
and this is the rear elevation
of the proposed
rear extension
this uh photograph shows you a view
towards the north bramley the adjoining
dwelling with the existing conservatory
in view here
and this is a view towards the rear of
the application property and the
adjoining dwelling
the
the plans on screen at the moment
if i refer you to the committee update
sheet
which includes reference to an
additional planning history item
referred to as twenty two forward slash
zero one one seven seven forward slash
ful this slide shows the approved plans
for the single story rear extension
which was approved by the local planning
authority in august officers were
satisfied with the scale
and design of this extension such that
the um
the officer approved the application
as demonstrated
by previous decisions officers do not
object to the principle of a
sympathetically scaled and designed
extension to the property
however in this instance the proposed
extension by reason of its unacceptable
scale and design
is considered to detract from the
historic authenticity of the cottage and
would significantly erode its historic
character
the proposals fail to prove preserve the
significance of the listed building
causing less of substantial harm
officers therefore recommend refusal for
the reasons set out in pages 22 and 23
of the agenda thank you chad emily thank
you very much indeed we'll call our
first speaker on this item who is mr
mark burstall of warmington and
also parish council
good evening councillor thank you very
much for your patience
you will have three minutes i'll give
you a third second morning for your
time's up if you could stay seated for
questions afterwards i'd be most
grateful otherwise whenever you're ready
the floor is yours thank you very much
good evening councillors
well this is a pretty
little old cottage that sits in a row of
buildings
facing onto the green in warmington
the emphasis there is on little
like so many properties of that era it's
very small and that creates a problem
for modern day families
which need more space
and it's no longer acceptable to sleep
three or four in one row
so when we saw this application for a
very modest two-story extension
hidden out of sight at the rear of the
building we were quite happy to say we
had no objection
the cottage on the green has no
particular architectural merit
or feature that needs protecting
and there is no record of it having any
specific historical
significance
so for the conservation officer to say
that there might be some small harm to
these elements
seemed to be rather unnecessary
for the planning officer to then make an
issue of this
and to make it a reason for refusal
is simply not comprehensible to us
in our view it is overstepping his remit
for the same reasons of size the
properties on either side of the cottage
on the green have both had significant
extensions to the rear
the one to the south
or the left hand side when viewed from
the green
is a large and dominant structure
which dwarfs this very modest proposal
i believe somewhere in the records there
is a picture of this in the case papers
i don't have a copy of it
but it's yet another reason we believe
the planning officer is wrong
councillor fielding will enumerate the
various course strategy paragraphs and
planning reasons
which are supportive of this application
so i will not duplicate
that
but i do endorse his views
we remain certain that there is no
reason to object to this application
i hope that you will agree with us
thank you
cancer burst thank you very much members
do we have any questions for our parish
councillor
no
thank you very much for your time and
contribution
okay we'll call our next speaker on this
item who is the applicant and agent i
believe so uh miss julia day and uh
julie keith is that right sorry chairman
um
sorry for the intrusion i've just found
out i have a um conflict of interest on
this one which i wasn't aware of until
immediately now so um
if you want to make your way i'll make
my way back that'd be great thank you
can you we probably should record
exactly what that um conflict is yeah
sorry i should have said i have a
professional relationship with the
architect and i wouldn't want that to uh
impeach the decision of the committee
very good thank you
okay sorry about that um now you have
three minutes between the two of you are
you both going to be speaking or is just
one of you going to be speaking
okay in that case you
you
bear with us and we will check
okay if you could give us a nod when you
want the slides to be moved on one we
will make sure that gets done otherwise
you'll have three minutes i'll give you
a 30 second warning as soon as you're
ready the time is yours
okay so you're not actually talking to
them they're just here for us to look at
is that right
okay can i just double check your
microphone is on
no it wasn't no it wasn't but it is now
okay we've got the photos up we will
have those scanned through as you're
speaking um and you'll have three
minutes i'll give you a 30 second
warning if you can stay seated obviously
for questions otherwise when you're
ready the time is yours thank you
following last year's refusal the scheme
now proposes a glaze link to the
extension providing visual transparency
which retains the views of the rear
elevation
it is also has a lower roof line and the
floor is positioned sorry the first
floor is positioned away from and not
attached to the rear wall
unfortunately we don't agree with this
scheme would result in any heritage harm
however even if it were the officer's
report is still not considered firstly
the full back position of the recent
approval or secondly has not undertaken
a balancing exercise as required by mppf
that is to balance any
any harm to the heritage asset is to be
weighed against any public benefits
arising from the proposal
the scheme is shown on my presentation
but it has been shown before
this scheme was judged by your officers
as not harmful
and so was approved fallbacks can be
considered in the planning balance you
can ask is the current application
significantly more harmful than that
already approved or would the effect be
similar or less harmful
i believe the proposed two-story scheme
which has the glaze link and similar
footprint to be equally not harmful as
the approved single story
in relation to the waiting exercise
government guidance says
works to enlisted building sorry works
to enlisted private dwelling which
secures its future as a designated
heritage asset could be a public benefit
in this case the public benefit which
outweighs any perceived harm will
provide much needed extra family
accommodation including
third bedroom where presently there's
only two
higher levels of installation
a ground floor kitchen dining room some
reconfiguration of the existing internal
arrangements to provide a downstairs wc
and cloak room at the moment there's
only one combined upstairs bathroom and
wc
therefore any heritage harm is offset by
the public benefits
if extended in this way the building
will provide additional flexible and
future-proofed accommodation for mrs
keith and her family these aspirations
are also supported by course
courts strategy policies policy s
8 in terms of the historic environment
30 seconds and policy s
2
sorry 20. without people like mrs keith
who are prepared to extend her home in a
sympathetic and thoughtful way i fear
the investment simply will not happen
and in the long term listed buildings
such as this will not be secure for
future generations
thank
you perfect thank you very much indeed
members do we have any questions either
for our agent or for applicants
councillor jennings please
evening um
pond cottage next door i mean obviously
this is part of a semi um so it's
originally was the same
does that have a two-story extension at
the back
how far does it go down
in
compared to
how far your extensions is your proposed
extension is coming out
i would say their extension
we'll we'll try and get some accurate
measurements if we can from our from
whatever we've got in our system i think
the officer showed a topographical
survey which probably shows that quite
well
we'll pull that up in points for
clarification any other questions for
either our applicant or our agent
no
in that oh cancer hence your servant
okay thank you
have you got any objections of your
neighbors doing this project
no i have their support okay so you're
surrounded by extensions which come out
okay thank you
okay unless there are any other
questions
no thank you both very much for your
time contributions even thanks for your
patience as well
okay our final speaker on this item is
cancer fielding um cancer fielding when
you have an opportunity if you want to
make your way forward um
you'll know that you'll have five
minutes i'll give you 30 second warning
you can use as much or as little as your
five minutes as you like whenever you're
settled and comfortable if you put your
microphone on the time will be yours
if you're before i start if you
i must make my usual request i am
dyslexic so i do
have difficulty sometimes in reading so
anyway i'm ready to start
okay
there are two contrasting assessments
provided in the in the committee report
that contradict each other one is the
case officer and the other by the
conservation officer
to be pr to precede the officer's report
the proposed development would be
classed as small scale
sub
servient in appearance and the materials
proposed to be in keeping with the main
property it would not have a detrimental
impact on the character and appearance
of the wider area
i do i would regard the proposal to
comply with cs11 the aonb and i consider
the proposal to accord with cs9 and cs20
the proposed extension cannot be seen
from the rear and the road
the conservation officer is only a tech
technical consultant
and should advise only on the degree of
harm
he has made no reference to any of the
points raised in the heritage statement
where the author refers to the
conservation officer's recommendations
he has made no sim
significant reference to what harm is
being caused this is a rough requirement
of nppf
to
2022
189-197
there are various legal appeal cases
that have you have before you
the comment made by two respected
authorities
jerry cargill qc and
gail stotten agree strongly that the
conservation officers
routinely make a finding of less than
substantial harm
and then go on to object or advise
refusals on an application
this is not what they're qualified
to do nor the npps says they should be
doing it
only the planning officer in possession
of all the facts in the case including
ones that do not relate to the heritage
is qualified to undertake
public benefit balance
lesson substantial harm can be taken
with public benefit
this would allow the work to comply with
nppf and cs8 both refer to the securing
its optimum viable use and the long-term
future use of the property
both nppf 1 9 6 and 202 and csh state
where a development proposal will lead
to less than substantial harm to the
significance of a designated heritage
asset the harm must be justified and
weighed against the public benefits of
the proposal
including securing its optimum and
viable use
the officer makes a recommendation based
on the development plan and the nppf
there is no np
ndp
only a parish plan and what is the
development plan referred to
so what are the reasons for refusal when
the officers already given her opinion
on the property the planning officer
states
stated in her report with the extension
cannot be seen the proposal development
would be classified as small scale and
i'm therefore satisfied there is no
harmful impact on the character of the
aonb and limit disruption to the
distinct vernacular character so why
refuse
how can
she go on to repeat the generalization
made by the conservation officer by
virtue of the proposed extension scale
design and location it is considered
that the design will not preserve the
building's architectural and historical
interest i disagree as cs-8 and nppf ask
for justifications of her opinion and
the public benefits
the public benefits are an additional
bedroom
a more manageable kitchen diner to
modern standards and in improving the
accommodation in the property as the
officer has stated i find a proposal to
accord with cs 9 and 20. i therefore ask
this application be granted
cancer fellaini thank you very much
indeed ma'am do you have any questions
for our ward member please
no in that case canceling thank you very
much for your time contributions even of
course your patience as well very boring
you didn't ask um
okay members do we have any points for
clarification
that shouldn't be up yet
we are not currently adjourned we are
still going uh do we have any points
clarification for officers councillor
jennings please
i'd like uh some photos or anything
which we have on the pond cottage
the other part of the semis attached
please
you're specifically wanting to be able
to determine whether or not the uh
extension that is part of that cottage
extends further than the the one that's
being proposed is that correct that's
correct yes thank you and just a
confirmation of its two stories as well
thank you
um i'm i'm not aware of any relevant
planning history available to us um as a
planning authority
related to a two-story rear extension um
however you can see here uh this is
google
aerial view this is the the pair of
cottages
oh sorry here this is the pair of
cottages you can see that that's the
existing conservatory
of the application site and this is pond
cottage it's difficult to ascertain from
a google aerial whether something is
single story or two-story however
there is a photograph available on
planning file this is from 2011
and as i say there's nothing since 2011
to indicate that this property was
subjected to an additional two-story
extension so this appears to be that
extension that we can see in the
aerial photography this is that
two-story extension and it does appear
um to extend rearwards at single storey
so it's ground floor level so if i just
refer back to that that's what you're
seeing you'll see there's two stages to
this this depth of extension okay could
i ask you about
on that picture because i'm looking at
that and i don't see any change in the
in the roof line it appears to go from
where your cursor is there
all the way back to what looks like
is it cars or something behind
wouldn't there be if there was a drop in
the roof level wouldn't there be a
change in the
i think we'd we're we're relying heavily
here it appears that we're relying
heavily on a google image that we have
no control over and we don't know what
date that was taken um you've seen a
side view that shows the uh roof line
going across for two stories and then
down for one that is an officer photo i
think i'd be more comfortable relying on
that
um but if i may jump i'm going to jump
in here with unless you've got more
questions
i think we saw one photo from the garden
and it showed something up in the top
right of the next door so
okay perhaps we could have a look at
some of the
those photos
might have been
this the only photograph you can see
it's difficult because you don't see the
full
um extension uh
it looks like that that could be
um
the the end of a gable perhaps because
it seems to jut upwards but i wouldn't
want to make any assessment or judgment
based on that because as i say you don't
get the full
view of the photograph and again that
could potentially be
the rear elevation there because you've
you've got some grayed out area which
may be the sort of the lead um
the lead roofer butting the brick
as i say i wouldn't want to make any
judgment either way on that
thanks um just follow up on on those if
i may you said there's no relevant you
can't find any relevant planning history
relating to that uh
that specific extension is that correct
which would suggest that it was done
prior to 2011. um do you know when the
listing was placed on either or both
buildings please
i only have the listing for um
it refers to two cottages so i will
base it that it could potentially have
been the both
and that indicates that it was 8th of
april 1987.
okay thank you
um and there's no planning history
relating to the uh of what appears to be
an extension next door
so we have no idea when that could have
been built not specifically related to a
two-story extension to that's what i
could see when i had a look on the
system just now thank you
anyone else have any points of
clarification
before we move into the debates no less
time to debate who would like to kick us
off
yes cancer mills
are your clarification if you've got a
point of clarification please ask it um
just ask um
and we ask about neighbors um
can any other neighbours see this
application
can they look onto it
i think it might have gone
in determining the harm to a list of
building you wouldn't necessarily um
base uh
the
the weight of the your decision on
whether it can be seen from a public
view but obviously there's a likelihood
that it could be seen from either
adjoining properties garden
um
but
obviously i wouldn't want
given that it's we're talking about harm
to the setting and the character of the
list of building we're talking more
about the list of building itself
impact on residential immunity of which
the officer has referred to in the
report and they're satisfied with the
residential impact thank you very much
council james before you ask your
question i think we might have found a
more up-to-date google image that will
demonstrate or should give you an
indication at least of the extent of the
uh
what appears to be a two-story and
single-story extension next door
okay this is um an app called google
earth pro and it has every google image
taken over the years so i've gone back
to 2017 this was taken
um let's see if this works
was it it's not zooming a little bit
more to make it a bit clearer
okay
so
this is the neighbouring property here
this is the two-story element and on
this one the shadows falling differently
so you can see the threshold where it
goes to single story behind and probably
the different texture in the tiles
showing the different age so that
confirms the picture from 2011 that that
was shown from the ground
constraints do you have another question
yeah i'm just trying to get an idea now
basically with this application is this
all about whether as a committee we are
we regard this as sympathetically scaled
or not
we consider that this the scale and the
design of the extension is such that it
it has an impact on the the character in
the setting of the listed building um
if it helps i could read out the
specific um consideration of the
conservation officer and their comments
so this is their their comments part of
their comments won't read them out fully
um
they say the two-story accentured would
mask or screen most of the rear and
appear as a domineering element the
first floor would truncate the rear the
effect would be accentuated with
vertical boarding and a large scale
ground floor aperture it would detract
from the vernacular composition and
disrupt the integrity and historic
authenticity of the rear elevation the
proposal would appear as an incongruous
feature within the historic setting
they do have other comments within it
but i thought that
summarized where they felt that harm was
arising from the scale and the design of
the extension
my final question it's more of a tech
one
the obviously the the one which is being
approved obviously
um
being only single story
what is the difference in height between
the fallback which is the single story
and this one
i i'd need some time to to measure that
because i don't have those measurements
to handle just really rough
i wouldn't like to give a rough
okay we'll take some time to measure
that now so um
could we bring up the gentleman we'll
just take a german now for a couple of
minutes if you want to take a quick
comfort break now now's the time to do
it this is not a coffee break this is
just an adjournment to get that
okay
i think we're all back um so we uh if
how many of you would please kindly
respond to cancer journeys
um the
single story extension that has been um
approved would measure 3.2 meters to the
ridge um and on the application before
you it's six meters to the ridge
okay i think is everyone happy with
their points of clarification now we can
move into debate in just a second
yes okay can't send your servant
right can i adjust that
how many bedrooms does the existing
cartridge go
two two
okay thank you anymore lastminute.com
no
um richard i think you've got uh some
information that uh would be helpful
when we're in debate please
uh just picking up on the point about
scale that's been discussed um scale
comes up at least three times in the
report firstly in the context of the
landscape impacts
where it's considered to be small scale
second in the context of design
distinctiveness uh where again it is
considered to be
small in scale and then thirdly in the
context of the historic environment
where the scale is considered to be
harmful
scale will differ dependent on what
you're looking at so in a landscape
context scale can be very different from
that at a detailed context of a listed
building so that's why there are
differences throughout the report
the officer recommendation in front of
you is solely on the scale of the
proposal in relation to the listed
building
therefore if it weren't listed the
recommendation may very well be
different
so just to help us understand and help
me understand this in terms of the
landscape impact it refers here to the
am aonb we're looking at the um uh scale
in terms of the aomb
which clearly is demonstrably larger
than the property itself whereas uh the
reason for refusal is specific to the
harm course to the listed building
and the scale in terms of the listed
building is that correct absolutely yeah
marvelous thank you for that okay let's
move into
debate
council dixon
thank you gentlemen um could i possibly
ask for a picture of the rear elevation
to be put up please because i want to
see exactly
that impact because i think
my mind is
going to the likes that
i don't think there's been sufficient
harm to this listed building so i'm
minded to think i'm going to be
supporting the application and not the
officer's uh
recommendation of refusal i think i'm
going to be in favor
but i'd like to uh
just see
the
now that is timber cladding at the
on the first floor and a glazed
patio window more or less patio doors on
the bottom
yep
okay thank you
uh
did you make a proposal then or are you
still making your mind up
i think i will be going against the
officer's recommendation i'm happy to
propose grant
okay i'm going to need to have planning
reasons we'll come back to you for those
different different giving a different
weight to the conservation officer's uh
view
okay council curses
thank you um
just looking at a few things in the
report
the joining
um
page 20 do not consider proposed
extension
would have any harmful impact in terms
of setting the listed building
um
next point no harmful impact would occur
to the character and appearance of the
conservation area
um the next paragraph no public benefit
um i think it has been demonstrated that
there would be public benefit because
on one hand yes we do want to conserve
our historic housing stock but we also
need to make it fit for purpose for the
21st century and i think
there it has been shown that would be
public benefit
and looking at cs20
um
other alterations modifications to
existing buildings will be of
appropriate scale subservient in
relation to the existing building
taking into account the site location
and cumulative impacts of previous and i
think when we look at the
other extensions or the the buildings
surrounding this
um
i think this would
not be of inappropriate scale
and i think i would like to find a way
of
granting this action
i'm assuming you're seconding then
councillor dixon's proposal is that fair
yes thank you
anyone else counselor adam
thank you chair
um
i'm a bit
um
i'm more minded to go with the officer's
recommendation i'll be honest
not necessarily so much with the scale i
agree with with some of the points made
and the location again
doesn't weigh as heavy on my mind but
the design
for me
is is one of the key bits that's rolling
around in my head in particular so
i think i'd be more inclined to go with
refuse on this one
are you proposing that we go officer
recommendation yeah thank you very much
council jennings
i like the design of this um
i like
and i think it works it blends well when
you have listed buildings and you have
glass walkways
connecting up
new bits to the building i've seen it
i've mentioned it before on grand
designs when you have castles and you
have glass walkways on to other
buildings
and it mixes old and new
i feel that it is sympathetically scaled
i don't think in my view not overbearing
but that's that's my view and i'll be
um going against the officer
recommendation on this
thank you very much councillor mills
yes thanks mr chairman i agree a lot has
been said here i mean i've underlined um
a couple of things here um
it says here i do not consider so that
any harmful impact in the terms of loss
or light although or or overbrain will
be cause any
neighboring properties
i don't think this
is harmful to the um to this uh
or this application not not not hard was
the uh
to building itself surrounding areas i
agree with matt um i i think this will
be look very very nice and
i have to say it's improvement i'm very
sorry it's an improvement what they've
got there already thank you mr chairman
thank you council mills anyone else
before i chuck mine because fleming
um
i don't see a problem with the size the
scale and everything else i'm just not
keen on these glass walkways but i'll
overlook that for for uh
to sort of support the other guys where
um
for modern living this this is an
essential extension to this house
um and whilst i say the glass walkway is
not my favorite part of it um
i'll be uh i'll
be going against the officer's
recommendation on that
thank you very much anyone else before i
have my bit
count senator seraphin thank you
um
no i'm in favor because modern day
living
these cottages are very small
there's no objections from neighbours
and this would improve
the people's well-being to live in a
property in modern day let me
[Music]
okay thank you very much indeed i'm
assuming no one has said anything to say
at this point so i will check mine in
i'm going to second cancer eden's
proposal to go with the officer's
recommendation um whilst i don't
particularly like the design that is
subjective
i don't have to live there someone else
does if they like it that's fine so i'm
not too concerned about that
what i am concerned about is the impact
on the listed building i do think it is
um quite a substantial
extension um and whilst it is a vast
improvement on what is there as council
mills has said we are very aware that uh
planning permission has been granted um
for something else that is a vast
improvement on what was already there so
i don't weigh that in my balance um when
considering the uh benefits
um a lot of the public benefits that
have been put forward to us
uh such as um an extra bedroom increased
living area are not public benefits
they're occupier benefits so i i take
that i consider that to be the case
rather than being a public benefit
however i do com understand that as
country and hendrick sarafin has just
said now
that we do need to be mindful of
modernizing and being able to bring um
buildings into the 21st century my
personal view is that the permission
that has already been granted does
exactly that
this for my mind and my money is
the design is too large
the scale is too much
and
causes significant harm that is not
outweighed by any benefit so i will be
going with the offer as a recommendation
but of course you're entitled to your
own views
we do have a proposal to uh grant the
application against the officer's
recommendation i just want to have a
clear understanding of exactly why you
want to go against the officer's
recommendation please
i disagree with the assessment as a
conservation officer that there is harm
to the listed building and i do don't
see it as uh as sufficient harm to
actually warrant a refusal
are you happy with that
um
yes um
there's
if if members find us harm then you'll
need to outweigh that with public
benefits what i've heard members say are
various levels of harm all very low
level or in some cases actually
beneficial so no harm at all
in the case of counselor jennings i
think it was
if if that's the view of committee and
you don't find harm and you go even
further and find benefit then you don't
need um you know public benefits
um
if you if you do find harm then you will
need public benefits and the things i've
heard as council richards just said
they're not public benefits they're
simply private benefits
yes thank you
okay we're happy to move forward with a
vote based on your uh assessment so the
proposal is to grant uh the application
sorry conditions
standard conditions do you have any
extra conditions you want to put liv is
liv is on fire tonight she's excellent
so glad she's here no additional
conditions no additional conditions
running through your list
okay uh firstly
there would there's obviously a full and
a list of building consent i'll go
through them separately uh and as
officers we would see delegated
authority for the the detailed wording
of it
uh of each one
the full application we would recommend
two conditions the standard time limit
and the approved plans
for the listed building application
would recommend five conditions and they
are number one standard time limit
number two approved plans
number three samples of materials
external materials
um
in fact that might not be just external
no that um do we know if that's external
and internal
we we would seek your delegated
authority to do the final detail of
whether that's internal as well i think
it's probably external
uh number four would be um details of
the windows doors and glazed frame of
the extension
and number five would be architectural
details of the eaves verges abutments
with the existing
and abutments with the existing house
thank you
thank you very much
can i go ahead
if i get to
live's going to tell me off again um
okay let's move on we have a proposal to
grant um the the application we've heard
the conditions could i please have a
show of hands in favor of granting the
application please
and those against
two abstentions
one committee therefore resolves now i
just uh i should have said this is for
the full application so committee
results do grant application 22 0 1 1 7
4 f u l we now obviously need to do the
same for the lbc i'm assuming the same
proposal i'm assuming the same second
thing i can remember who it was now yeah
it's been seconded so uh same conditions
as you've just heard could have a show
of hands in favor of the lbc
seven
against
two abstentions one committee therefore
resolves to grant 22 0 1 175 lbc
marvelous thank you very much let's move
on to our final application of the
evening
which is application reference tpo
one three 20113 that is at five alveston
pastures in stratfor upon ivan
our presenting officer is elena bass um
and will just make herself comfortable
and as soon as you're ready on the
floor's yours
okay members if i could draw your
attention back now
and it is set up and ready to go so our
presentation officer says and as soon as
she shed her screen she will begin
thank you chair
this item relates to tree preservation
order tpo forward slash 201
forward slash 131 which was served on
the 28th of march 2022.
the trees subject of the tpo are located
at five alveston pastures which lies
approximately 1.8 kilometers to the east
of the edge of stratfor town and is
identified by the black dot on the plan
the site is located within the open
countryside and is at the end of a row
of five dwellings
the tree preservation order relates to a
total of 15 trees t1 and t2 are oak
trees at the front of the site as shown
on the plan
g1 is a group of 13 trees consisting of
four lime trees
three norway maples three ash two horse
chestnuts and one oak
all trees are a and b class
the plan in front of members is a copy
of the tree preservation order and it
should be noted that within g1
three trees are marked with an x on the
plan and have been identified as being
excluded from the order
this slide provides a more detailed plan
of the trees subject to the protection
order with the approximate locations of
them circled in red
this is an aerial view of the site and
shows the approximate location of the
trees subject of the order
the tpo was served following concerns in
respect of potential development at the
site and following the submission of a
current pending planning application
this slide shows a plan submitted as
part of the planning application which
details a permitted development fallback
of a tennis court and outbuildings in
the area of the tpo trees members will
note the annotation to the plan which
states existing trees to be lawfully
removed to facilitate installation of
tennis court and incidental buildings
i now have some photos
here we are stood at the road to the
west of the site with the trees subject
of the order to the left hand side of
the road
this is a street scene photo taken from
google from july 2019 and shows the
trees again to the left of the road in
leaf
we're now to the east of the site
showing a view of the trees when
approaching from along the road
and this is a photo taken from within
the site
again showing the group of trees subject
to the tpi
there is one update to the report as
detailed within the update sheet
chairman members have three options as
to how to determine the order as set out
on page 34 of the agenda
for the reasons set out in the committee
report it is officer's recommendation to
confirm the true preservation order with
a modification to the title to remove
reference the adjacent roadside verge as
set out on page 35 of the agenda
thank you very much indeed let's call
our first speaker on this item who are
mr blackwell our landowner and uh mr
elliott goodall our agent if you'd both
like to make your way forward to the
chairs in front of you
now gentlemen are you both speaking or
just one of you
just yourself
you're here for questions okay perfect
and that goes from the back wall uh
you'll have three minutes i'll give you
a 30 second one before your time is up
otherwise when you're ready if you press
the button in the middle it'll turn red
and the floor is yours
great thank you
okay
i'm speaking today to object to the
imposition of a tpl on my property for
the following reasons
reason one the imposition of the tpo is
premature the site is subject of a live
planning application along with the
change of use of the garden land upon
which the trees reside to non-garden
land proposes the ongoing protection
maintenance and management of the trees
which are covered by the tpo
the proposed works which include the
provision of a tennis court on land
beyond the root protection area of any
trees includes the provision of a
designated length area that would
encapsulate these trees and enable them
to benefit from an extended period of
management and care by statutory
obligation this would be an
agriculturalist led with updated reports
submitted at prescribed intervals over a
10-year period
the serving of the tpo does not commit
us to any level of care or maintenance
of the trees which is the opposite of
what we have proposed under the
application it simply prevents their
removal this is short-term thinking and
the proposed application has a far
greater benefit to the trees than the
simple imposition of a tpo
reason two agriculture the tree survey
by focus environmental
commissioned and paid for by myself that
has been used as supporting evidence for
the tpo notes notes that most of the
trees within greek group 1 are grade b2
and b3 and c despite their projected
longevity without management due to the
very closely packed nature of the
coppice the trees are likely to get
worse over time rather than better it is
natural for trees packed together to
grow in a narrow narrow vertical manner
this makes them unbalanced which can
lead to falls in high winds and a danger
to life
the maintenance of them would therefore
provide a far greater benefit than the
tpo there is evidence of ash die back on
two of the trees in d1 and there are
numerous dead branches on all of the
trees due to the due to the path nature
of the coppice which will require
regular maintenance and pruning
reason three unnecessary devaluation of
our property
the tp the imposition of the tpo would
unnecessarily
necessarily devalue our property
reason 4 justification
ironically i agree with the council's
view that the trees are of value and
they have benefit to the setting of the
property the submission of the live
planning application which includes
obligations to protect and care for the
trees clearly demonstrate our desire to
retain them the argument therefore
of the imposition of the tpo for
expediency to prevent their removal is
therefore invalid
the council insisted as part of our
application that we submit a lawful
development certificate to build a court
on the land where the trees are located
it's a full back position
on which we to assess our current
planning application against
this is despite us stating that we
wanted to retain the trees
this lawful development certificate is
now being used against us in the
imposition of the tpo to infer there is
a threat to the trees where none exists
in reality
since i or my family have no intention
of removing any of the trees within my
ownership i consider the tpo is
unnecessary and unreasonable and it
should be removed
mr blackwell thank you very much indeed
remember to have any questions for
either our speaker or our agent
no
oh can i send you seraphim yeah so
am i right you will not remove any of
the trees it's not our intention to
remove any of the trees at all
but
do you want me to give you a bit of a
history about
how this has all come about
it's just i i i you your opportunity to
do that was during your three minutes
i'm afraid you've answered this question
so i'm gonna have to stop you yeah so
you just want a simple yes or no yeah no
thank you any other questions members
council curtis
thank you yes and i was trying to follow
you know obviously you're speaking
quickly did you you said something about
uh was it a lemp yes
i didn't
[Music]
ecology and management plan
and as part of the live application that
we have ongoing at the moment we're
proposing to impose a landscape ecology
management plan on the area of the trees
this will seek to maintain them
under the agriculturalist plan which is
a 10-year plan which we proposed it will
also we're seeking to improve the area
and introduce biodiversity with bat
boxes and bird boxes
and also introduce wildflower into the
area as well to introduce native bee
species as well
so the issue with the tpo is that we
cannot do anything to the trees with the
bird boxes the bad boxes we can't touch
them in respect of maintenance
unless we submit
um
[Music]
uh we unless we submit applications to
the council which will not only waste
the council's time but also will be
expensive for the council and for us
thank you very much members do you have
any other questions for our agent or
applicant
no in that case gentlemen thank you very
much your time and contribution this
evening and your patience as well
our final spike speaker of the evening
councillor rolfe good evening and
welcome
that's right if you want i think you've
got an idea of the drill you've got five
minutes 30 second warning um as much
time or as little time as you like
whenever you're ready time's yours um
it's absolutely vital to understand that
the applicant has absolutely no
intention of cutting down trees and that
the planning authority saw the lawful
development certificate as a threat to
the trees the lawful development
certificate was only submitted on the
advice of the local planning authority
all will be made absolutely clear when
the revised planning application for the
tennis court is looked at either
delegated for approval or by this
committee
which back in may u.s committee
suggested this happen
if this tpo is upheld it will mean that
the applicant will never be able to
maintain the trees on his own property
he won't be able to put back boxes on
so when the next application comes
through
where he's got the the
is it lamp
uh that will look after all these trees
and maintain them forever and ever and
ever
that simply won't be able to be done
and it will just make it really really
difficult
so if it's upheld then then he just
won't be able to go near the trees now
two of the trees are have evidence of
ash dieback
if you if you say that a tpo goes on
them now those trees will just sit there
just dying
and no one would be able to touch them
he won't be able to touch trees on his
own land which he wants to keep and he
wants to preserve he wants to look after
so
all i can say is that you either you
either defer
a decision on this
on the tpo to till the
until you hear the the well i don't know
what's going to happen to the
application because it may be that the
planning officer
um
refuses that it may be that that she
supports it i don't know but
i think it's vital that you understand
the whole context
of the application that will come
forward it probably won't come forward
till october now
but he is not going to touch these trees
believe me but then
if you put tpo on them nobody will be
allowed to touch them
thank you
casaroth thank you very much indeed
members do you have any questions for
cancer off please
no in that case cancer off thanks for
your time contribution and your patience
members let's uh move two points for
clarification for officers i have a
series of questions cancer dixon's
signal first start to let him go first
as just a comment there that if a tpo
goes on there's nothing that can be done
i must believe a tpo can be removed is
that correct under certain circumstances
i believe so
um yes if there is a tree preservation
order on a tree um then an application
can be made for works to that tree um or
removal of that tree and that would be
assessed at that point
well if an application was submitted to
remove the um the tree then that would
be um
assessed at that point
to have the the tree removed but there
wouldn't be a lifting of the tpo at that
point i'll approach that a slightly
different way if i may so um i've got a
few questions especially it might be
worth you coming and joining us up here
because you may be able to answer it so
for clarity sebastian is our tree
preservation officer or the expert on
this so he'll be able to give us a bit
more clarity
um
so we've heard in in circumstances so if
we were to uh agree um and confirm the
order is made um any work that may need
to be done to either the group of trees
or the two individuals t1 and t2 would
need to have permission is that correct
consent and that would include adding
any back boxes or anything else
yes but they'd be considered very minor
it works to
install the back box so and that's a
simple application to the council is
that correct yes correct marvelous okay
um
if uh so we've heard about a future
planning application coming forward um
uh if
within that application as we've heard
there is a i think it was a lemp is what
we were told which is essentially a
management plan for those trees were to
come forward is that an opportunity then
to lift that tpo or remove that tpo
knowing that we have that management
plan in perpetuity attached to the
property
so could we remove the tpo from the
trees so if a planning application was
granted um then
as part of that then
obviously that's in discussions at the
moment there is no um planning
application granted at the moment but
there may be
um
agreements as part of that to create a
managed area um and that would um
allow for
a management plan over a series of years
off those trees
i don't know if richard wants to
confirm that
um
yeah
the the the length that's been referred
to would allow for
certain works to be done
some of those works may also need um the
consent under the tpo at the time
um so the lent wouldn't allow works to
the tpo without a tpo application being
made
i'm going to make myself a little more
clear if i can
under what
circumstances can a tpo once made be
then be removed so no longer exist so if
we put a tpo on those t1 t2 and g1
on what circumstances can that then be
removed so there will then be no tpo on
those when the when the trees are failed
and that could be agreed under an
application to the council to allow the
filling of the church so it's only if
they're fed does that tpo go away
yes i think so unless yeah the serving
is indefinite from the point
okay so we can't remove it unless it's
being felt no got it that's helpful
that's exactly what i wanted to get to
um so the lem
that we've heard about that could give
permission
uh to the landowner to the occupier of
the of the property to be able to
conduct certain works the those tpo
trees without applying for consent
because they've already been granted it
as part of that lump is that correct
no they'd still need to because it's
under a different part of the act they'd
still need to apply for a tpo tpo works
as well as the lamp okay so regardless
of uh so if the tpo is confirmed and
made
regardless for any future applications
they would have to come to the uh the
council and get permission to do
anything
correct yes right yes we're there i
think that hopefully has that certainly
helped me and i think hopefully it's
helped you as well council jennings
can we put on this application can we
put tpos on
for instance t1 and t2 but not
but only on half of g1
um
within the um committee report um there
are um
essentially three three ways that
members could vote they can confirm the
order as made
um or confirm the order with
modifications so yes if members felt
that
certain trees should be removed from the
tree preservation order then
modifications can be
made to it
and so one final question um
on the grades of the trees
um
i said i don't know how that how the
grades work is i mean is it grade
abc or is it a b c d e f g or is it just
what are they
because i'm trying to work out which
if these any of these trees
obviously i appreciate t1 and t2 i
understand that
their grade
grade a
but um a lot of them in
area g1 appear to be
both
b2s and b3s
and yes that's correct so um t one and t
uh well t one has been um identified as
a b category
tree t2 is an a category and then um all
of those within the group um have been
identified as b category
you'll see from the plan on screen now
that there are three
x's within that group area and they are
identifying trees um that are of a
lower value and therefore do not
form part of the
um group order so they they haven't um
that they're not of an a or b class
value to be worthy of um that the group
order at that point so excluded from the
tpa
finally one question can i can i see g1
again please
because i'm just trying i was trying to
write down all the numbers
quickly
okay
two one
so i think
from
the clarification you were seeking
am i correct in understanding that
we
we wouldn't be able to put a tpo on as a
temporary measure
until the left no i just wanted to get
that absolutely clear a tpo is for life
in terms of um
natural conservation and upkeep of trees
it's
what's allowed under a tpo anyway or is
are you essentially not allowed to touch
it at all i mean essentially i'm
thinking if
if there's a windfall of a branch and
things what's
allowed within a tpo that you don't have
to get an application for
the only exempt works would be the
removal of dead
dead or dangerous trees and dead wood is
also exempt from an application form as
well
cancer flaming
um
my understanding of a tpo is to preserve
the tree in good health and to keep it
keep its i mean it's a tea protection
order saying that you you can't do
anything to it nobody expects a tpo or
owner of a tpo tree to sit back and
watch it fall down so on a regular basis
tree maintenance is approved and looked
well on i mean i dealt with deal with
these parish council-wise so
you know
arborealists always look very favorably
if you want to maintain these trees and
don't make life difficult for you so
to say that once you put a tpo on it you
can't touch it for life it's it's really
unfounded and
you know that the thing is it ensures
that the the trees are maintained over a
period of time so
from that perspective i
i would
say have you got a question
are you it sounds like you're debating
now i thought you were going down a
question line i'm really sorry i'll just
stop i think
i think the question that might have
been asked there was um what work can be
undertaken to a tpo tree and just
general uh
maintenance of it without requiring an
application to the council
sebastian's already answered the point
about dead wood and dead trees being
removed beyond that any application
would need
a works to tpo application
we deal with hundreds of those every
year because we've got tpos and it's a
perfectly normal part of the council's
work that it assesses whether they're
acceptable or not and then allows them
to go ahead or otherwise
thank you
[Music]
can i just step in and
refer members to the committee report
where it says that the serving of the
tpo is not intended to prevent
appropriate future management of the
trees or offer an imposition
and
any
essentially future works just need to
come forward through an application but
it's not intended to stop any works to a
tree in the future
cancer crumb
just a very brief one thank you um
from the sounds of it the tpo is
indefinite and irrespective who owns the
application owns the site
a lemp
does is that just
incumbent on the the people who put it
in or is that if the place was sold
would the them still be in place as well
the length has been mentioned but it's
not strictly relevant to what's in front
of members tonight because that may or
may not come forward as part of a
planning application which is a separate
matter
anyone else
any other questions no let's move into
debate and discussion cancer jennings
first
i'm happy to propose that we go for
option number two
which is a confirmation with
modifications and the modifications
would go would be
to go with
the tpo on
t17 on this map 216
t14
t13
t11
um we will need to have a clear uh
understanding of why uh you don't want
to include the other trees
um
what reason do i have to give
your reason
let me help i'm assuming you think that
the other trees are not as sufficient
value in order to confirm an order on
them i'm happy to go with that
cancer dixon please
i was going to go and do that the other
way in truth and basically say i'm not
going to support the tpo
are you proposing that
i'm happy to propose it yes
and
presumably for the same reason that you
don't think any of the trees on the side
are of uh sufficient value or age yes
et cetera et cetera um council jennings
i have assumed that you had proposed
yours before given what you had said
just to confirm
thank you councillor curtis
um
i
am sympathetic to the to the owner of
the property
however i think
yeah i mean i i get to preservation
um amendments or requests
coming frequently um
it's i don't think it seems particularly
onerous that if there is a tpo on a tree
that the the process for having work
done on that doesn't seem to be yeah
particularly onerous
um
and
while the current owner
may be
you know very environmentally conscious
and i would want to see all of these
trees preserved
we don't know what the position of any
new owners
might be
and i would
support the officer's recommendation
that we have this in full
is that proposal yes
casa crump
um
not often in agreement with cancer the
courageous
well right sometimes i agree with kev
said but on this case not i totally
support him i'm happy to second
i haven't seen the evidence that says we
don't need the tpos and i haven't seen
the evidence it says we need the tpo but
we'll take a few out so i'm in agreement
with councillor curtis and i'm happy to
support his proposal thank you that's
just to confirm that it's the second
thing i'll do
thank you
um okay anyone else wish to speak
councillor fleming
um
i
am going to support the tpo um i mean we
had a lot of mention about ash dieback
and whatever else and other problems
those can be handled through separate
applications to the arborealist and they
can be corrected quite easily um so from
my perspective i'll be supporting the
the officer's recommendation
marvelous thank you very much
okay anyone else wishing to speak before
we start going through the proposals
no okay so we have a proposal to confirm
the tpo as made has been made by
councillor curtis and seconded by crump
that is the only one that has been
put forward proposed and seconded we
also have um a
we also have a proposal uh from
councillor jennings um to remove
uh
trees now i'm going reverse from where
you did it just so we're clear um remove
trees one two three four five six nine
and ten
and make the tpo on the other so this is
option two that is to modify um as laid
out um and uh from council dixon
to not make the tpo at all now um could
i please see if there are any seconders
either for cancer jennings or for cancer
dixon's proposals
okay unless there is
it's your last chance
okay chance is gone all right so we only
have one proposal and that is to make
the tpo so could i please have a show of
hands
subject to the modification i set out in
uh our
document pack could i please have a show
of hands for those in favor of making
the tpo and the modification
five those against
and abstentions
committee therefore resolves to make the
tpo uh
subject to modification of title to
exclude the wording and adjacent
roadside verge um we have no further
applications i don't believe we have any
urgent business no in that case members
thank you very much for your time
contribution this evening officers again
thank you very much for your time
particularly for keeping me on the
straight and narrow and of course to
everyone that's contributed from the
public and today we will see in a couple
of weeks thank you very much